lo que quiero ver en este vídeo es
explorar la noción de matriz y la
palabra matriz en inglés se dice matrix
y es por eso que recordé la trilogía de
las películas donde salía a keanu reeves
y si recuerdan es una película que
hablaba sobre una realidad virtual
creada por super computadoras y además
la relación que hay con este concepto en
matemáticas es decir la matriz es de
suma importancia en las ciencias de la
computación y por eso es que me acordé
de esta película porque con una matriz
construye es lo que se usa en los
gráficos de computadoras así que eso
súper inteligentes robots de esta
película que crean la matrix la matriz
en la película probablemente usaban
matrices para crear esta realidad
virtual en la que estaban todos
atrapados pero bueno que es realmente
una matriz pues esa es una respuesta
facilita una matriz es simplemente un
arreglo rectangular de números así que
mejor vamos a ver un ejemplo para que
quede mucho más claro esto supongamos
que me tomo la matriz 10 menos 7 y 5 y
que otro número puedo tomar 11 perfecto
la matriz tiene fíjate bien va a tener
una dos tres columnas esta matriz tiene
tres columnas y por otro lado tiene dos
filas estos dos conceptos nos van a
ayudar a definir la dimensión en la
matriz tenemos dos filas por tres
columnas y por lo tanto a esta matriz m
se le conoce como una matriz dos por
tres una matriz dos por tres es decir
una matriz dos por tres es aquella que
tiene dos filas por tres columnas dos
filas y tres columnas y ya esto es justo
lo que se le conoce como la dimensión de
una matriz a ver vamos a ver otro
ejemplo a ver si nos quedó mucho más
claro este ejemplo sencillo la matriz
que tenga solamente el 1 pues ésta es
una matriz uno por uno tiene una fila y
una columna a ver un ejemplo un poco más
difícil la matriz que tiene a los
números 37 y 17 bueno esta matriz tiene
una fila y tiene tres columnas por lo
tanto es una matriz uno por tres a ver
si ya nos va quedando mucho más claro
vamos a ver un ejemplo un poquito más
difícil para que vaya asentando el
conocimiento voy a hacer esta matriz más
larga
para ver la dimensión de esta matriz
vamos a tomar la matriz 3 500 menos uno
y menos siete este parece un -1 bueno
esta matriz va a tener una dos tres
filas y va a tener dos columnas por lo
tanto va a ser una matriz tres por dos
va a ser una matriz tres por y esperen
mejor déjenme ponerlo con el mismo color
va a ser el color rojo para las filas
que son tres filas tres por el color
verde para las columnas que son dos
columnas es una matriz tres por dos y
esta es la dimensión y bueno además cada
uno de estos numeritos que están adentro
de la matriz se le conoce como entradas
aquí tenemos la entrada del 1 la entrada
del 0 la entrada menos 7 etcétera y
bueno yo sé que tal vez no se ve tan
clara la relación que hay entre una
matriz y la película matrix es decir
entre esto y esto sin embargo lo que sí
les quiero decir es que una matriz es
una representación de un montón de
números podríamos decir que es una forma
compacta de obtener y tener una
información y realmente si son muy
importantes para verlos
en una computadora porque imagínate que
en una de estas entradas puedas tú tener
la intensidad de un cierto color de un
cierto pixel
tal vez las coordenadas un cierto punto
o lo que se te puede ocurrir y bueno una
de las ideas de toda esta serie es
trabajar con las operaciones algebraicas
las matrices es decir cómo se suman dos
matrices por ejemplo cómo se restan dos
matrices cómo se multiplica una matriz
por un número escalar cómo se
multiplican dos matrices diez más vamos
a llegar hasta ver cuál es la transporta
y la inversa de una matriz y entonces
con estas operaciones algebraicas que
vamos a utilizar en las matrices después
de que tú puedas multiplicar matrices y
sumar matrices y todo eso entonces tú
vas a poder obtener un resultado
completamente distinto y que va a poder
servir para que corra mucho mejor el
juego pero bueno hasta aquí vamos a
dejar la noción de qué es una matriz y
en los vídeos posteriores vamos a tratar
de cómo manejar estas matrices con sus
operaciones y tal vez cuando tú estás
estudiando la carrera y veas materias
como álgebra lineal vas a entender mucho
mejor cómo se aplican estas
matrices para representar cualquier cosa